all right sit here forgive me I am
finishing reading up apparently JJ
Abrams is talking again in his very
cryptic way and there's think pieces on
it and yeah I'm not gonna deal with that
because it's all speculative as this
stuff usually tends to be so you
probably guess new glasses frames I
don't know if I like these or not but
they arrived so I'm testing them out
okay here we go
greetings from Scotland did you get yes
I guess I did hear about Notre Dame and
that I mean that's that sort of thing is
is always gonna be kind of bummed out
depressing and you know what there we go
I knew something felt wrong yeah I think
I definitely don't like these glasses
more I look at him I'm just not feeling
them anyways ah love the specs ok I mean
like I'm figuring him out I think the
thing is I feel like they're I feel like
the top is hired kind of wish they were
a little bit lower down than that I
don't know I'm still figuring him out
anyways heard the towers are ok yeah the
the spire was what collapsed the tower I
mean did it's not like Notre Dame has
never suffered damage before but it's
still you know it's not not exactly a
happy thing oh the glasses well yeah I
do love this shirt i I I will always
love this shirt for as long as it lasts
you redecorated your face gear I don't
like them oh well played makes you look
like a librarian ah
uh maybe we should give them to Liz the
other ones better in my opinion
ravenclaw from Gardnerville an hour away
from Reno okay
anyways so Cheers no nobody has to drink
question yet but let's just get started
ten and thirteen would be such good
friends and will complement each other's
long coats hey they had a moldy doctor
story would be kind of cute and
interesting wouldn't it yes space-like
[Laughter]
okay gotta work with that uh seddie Oh
said evening without my Hufflepuff from
Scotland tag how would we know who you
are once a drink question I if you look
at my Twitter feed I'd said that I'd set
up anytime I get asked these things in
the chat you you should take a drink of
course now that I've said that someone
is gonna go to the Twitter just start
asking it so that drinks will happen but
I'm like it's not for real we've just
kind of joked about there are certain
questions that get asked very regularly
and or that I expect to get asked and
you know take a drink what do you think
of my alternate title for the crispy
promo video that was those no that was a
neat little idea I did like that some
people call me the space librarian best
and worst Doctor Who titled ooh um like
I'm not entirely sure how to judge I
mean like honestly best title there's
something about the empty child I've
always just found really engaging as a
title but as far as worst it's hard to
say because most the ones where I'm like
that's not a good title that title is
still appropriate to the
to the tone so Mike I'm not sure it's
like in my mind a bad title needs to be
unpleasant to the ear but also like
unrepresentative so like mummy on the
Orient Express
that's a dumb title but that's also what
the episode is dinosaurs on a spaceship
dumb title but descriptive and also fits
with the tone of the things so trying to
think of a worst title for Doctor Who
that's that's a bit tough I mean if you
want to go back to classic Doctor Who
and the Silurians that time that they
forgot that Doctor Who is not the guys
actually an actual name I mean that's
probably worst of all time just for that
gaff favorite cereal growing up I'm
really boring plain Cheerios oh but I
will put fresh honey on them I never
liked honey nut cheerios but I would I
would have a bowl of regular Cheerios
with soy milk I actually have a weird
nostalgia for sewing though because I
grew up drinking it um and I know
drizzle fresh honey on that so that
would that was cereal growing up are you
ever gonna rank through generations yes
eventually when I don't know I I really
try not to do more than one Doctor Who
list a month just because I I don't want
to burn through stuff too quickly and
also you know I'm I don't want to feel
like I'm grasping for list ideas I think
I've still got decent ones no battle of
vivo Lasker blam or whatever okay yeah
the back I think I might actually be
able to remember it the Battle of rank
score of colos I think that's only
because I've seen it written a lot like
that yeah yeah and and also as as do
bagful very astutely boy dad pointed out
they forgot to put a battle in it so you
know not even has the excuse of being
descriptive of the episode Magician's
apprentice wishes familiar were terrible
titles of essence they have nothing to
do with their stories I guess they don't
but I still like
like I did I find them orally pleasing
that's a you are relief please not
orally pleasing that's something else
love your glasses are these in it yeah
yeah I like I pretty much always I mean
I'll get my updated prescriptions you
know from from a local optometrist but
like actual frames these are Zen ease
because they're always less expensive a
Cheerios of Daleks oh man Daleks cereal
needs to be a thing I'm kind of shocked
it isn't although I guess there's like
weirdly specific rules about
merchandising with BBC properties and
also like the Daleks I think is still
partially controlled by the nation of
state I don't know that'd be weird but I
would so eat those even if they were
awful
hufflepuff from Cornwall it was a minor
spat not a battle so much I thought the
Lazarus experiment was bad do they mean
Methuselah no one came back from the
dead that's a valid point actually I
hadn't even thought about that one
there's one more reason I can have to
not really like that episode what's your
favourite TARDIS interior well I'll rank
those eventually but like top contenders
are usually the the one from the the
movie that was the debut of the 8th
doctor and Matt Smith's first one I
liked in both cases I like the whimsy of
those interiors my seven-year-old would
love Daleks Ariel the small disagreement
of what's its face krispies I'm back
video from a couple of days ago the
ovary the overacted argument of reign of
Rands court in new mexico i I did have
fun I guess was about two weeks back
when I asked people to give me incorrect
names for that episode
that was fun I should do stuff like that
more often anyways so I I'm trying to
figure out what I want to talk about cuz
like part of me is debating whether or
not to talk anymore about Star Wars
right now but I I don't know really what
else there is to bring up considering
that no I still have not seen flash I
don't know what I'm gonna get to
honestly I mean I'm I'm sure I'll enjoy
it well enough but like I'm so behind
from where I want to be and I've got a
show this weekend that I'm trying to
prep for and then I've got another show
two weeks after that that I need to prep
a whole new number for so I just don't
think I have the time to get to Shazam
ranked the top ranked the TARDIS
exteriors the thing is I'm sure there
are people who have because there are
the little tiny tweaks from version to
version I bought a new cosplay by total
accident how did you accidentally buy a
new cosplay now I'm curious
DC made a good move besides Wonder Woman
Oh Shazam I'm presuming you mean yes
that's what I've heard
but hmm episode nice probably gonna be
the most boring movie in the series I
just feel nothing I don't know if it I
don't think see the thing is I don't
think you can accuse any of the Star
Wars movies of being boring except for
attack of the clones for all the things
that they are they're not boring even
last Jedi which I didn't like wasn't
boring so I don't expect episode 9 to be
boring I just oh and like when I did the
video and a lot of people pointed this
out in the comments when I did the video
I didn't know that it had been confirmed
that yeah that is Palpatine's laughs and
he is and he is coming back in some
capacity so I guess I've got what about
eight months to come
the terms with that cuz I still hate it
and even if it's like a force ghost or
whatever I still hate it
like I can't think of a version that I
don't hate that idea
oh fellow gender-fluid very nice the Oh
a is great and watch the whole show yeah
I haven't seen that one yet I do want to
try and get to it how was your day my
day was pretty standard I've had I've
had some really exhausting days lately
work has been very draining so what's
your current off the top of your head
ranking of the doctors Oh God okay so
let me see if I'm doing all of the Canon
ones that's 14 of them so let me think
here at the bottom so Davison is at the
bottom then it's the war doctor then
it's Hartnell then might actually be
Tennant and then Pertwee then Colin
Baker he he's bumped up quite a bit
since I've been listening to Big Finish
but his time on the on the show still
drags it down a bit then Paul McGann
Christopher Eccleston Sylvester McCoy
Matt Smith Patrick Troughton I'm not
putting Whitaker on this list actually
now that I think about it so just I
realized I realize I got this far along
and I should have had her by now and I
didn't but she's not going on the list I
I must have forgotten somebody voted
every Oh Tom Baker Peter Capaldi I'm not
gonna put Whitaker on the list until it
runs done I'm just not gonna do it I'm
same reason I'm not gonna give my
overall opinion of of
or like compare him to Moffat or or
Davies and until he's done because you
know for as many of the issues as I saw
it was Series 11 I want to see if it
gets better so there we go a favorite
movie you've seen so far this year
mine is us or Pet Sematary er neither of
which I've seen I don't really want to
see Pet Sematary I want to see us but
it's not out anywhere near me um best
movie I've seen so far this year
actually uh lego movie part 2 which I
like pretty well when I saw it I liked
it a lot more after I saw it a second
time and took my kid to it and the more
I think about it the more I really
really really like that movie um
actually one of the songs if you even if
you haven't seen the movie there's a
song off the soundtrack called
everything's not awesome which is kind
of become a bit of a comfort food song
for me
lately which is just great
your LGBT videos were my intro to your
channel I've loved them since thank you
thank you for that yeah the next lgbtq+
video goes up Friday so how did your
taxes go get them in on time um yeah I
did so now I'm broke um yeah this this
year was a was a very different year for
me tax wise versus previous years and it
was in a lot of ways an expensive
learning experience because this is the
first year I had to file taxes with you
know with a patreon pulling in enough
that I had to file for it and it wasn't
the first year that YouTube was big
enough that I had to declare it as as
income but it was significantly more
than before so I've got a lot Wow
I had I learned a very expensive lesson
in how to keep track of your deductible
expenses cuz I had a lot more than i
deducted I just didn't keep proper track
of the dang
so there you go
yes I do plan to go see Avengers endgame
like I'm kind of letting Shazam pass me
by because even though I've heard it's
really good it's not something I haven't
inherent like I want to see that I just
kind of want to see it because I've
heard it's really good um but uh endgame
yeah I will make time to see endgame so
that's that's not even a question
let's see another thing to look forward
to on Friday
oh well good and now I'm broke how
relatable yeah yeah
gotta go bye okay see you TV and sin
have a good one were CGI and modern whoo
off the top of your head I mean my go-to
will always be the Lazarus monster I
mean just the design wasn't good and he
was so poorly integrated into the scene
like it was it was not good at all have
you ever gotten into D&D oh yeah oh yeah
it used to be part of a gaming group I
suppose technically I still am but it
doesn't really mean anymore because Paul
who ran it had another kid so he can't
really host anymore but trying to think
what was I last last time we did actual
D&D cuz we did a lot of different things
we did last time we we met together we
did cyberpunk we did a Star Wars
campaign at one point we did
transformers campaign I would call it
Cthulhu um well last time we actually
did D&D like straight up I I was a bard
last time and the time before that I was
a half work barbarian yeah so not
especially inventive and character
builds I have to admit as an adopted kid
I like seeing my brethren be the good
guys in Shazam and not evil orphans the
trope needs to die already oh yeah oh
yeah my parents died so now I'm evil
yeah that we don't and like the thing
with so many of those tropes is like
they're doubly awful because they're
they can be hurtful and do damage if
they're widespread enough but even
beyond that the reason that they're true
another word for a trope is a cliche
it's tired it's played out retirement
God's sake do you think the collector is
still alive um no no I don't cuz I mean
like when when we saw the collectors
space in an infinity war it was cracked
there's no reason that Thanos wouldn't
have killed him it's not impossible for
him to come back because we didn't see
him die but I don't think he's alive
he's he's toast for my money do you know
I do you know I'm tired do you know the
McElroy brothers I have heard of them
III don't really I haven't followed
their work have you washed Harmon quest
I watched the first season apartment
quest
I liked it well enough but I mean I
listened to improvised weapons that is
my D&D fix and I'm really addicted to it
so and full disclosure I'm actually
friends like personal friends with some
of the people in it and I support their
patreon but if you've never listened to
improvised weapons please - it's so good
I so see you as a bard hahahaha yeah
yeah like I I have really bad luck with
with gaming bills because I have a long
history of coming developing a character
that for whatever reason just ends up
being the least helpful for the
situations we get ourselves into it's
like every time I build a combat focused
character we end up dealing with these
magical things that completely - you
know make me completely unhelpful
anytime I make a non-combat
turn or support character turns out
everything's combat and I needed to like
just bring a big axe like I think the
only time that I proved to be notably
useful was in the Star Wars campaign
because I was a droid I was a droid
slicer which is the Star Wars gaming
equivalent of a hacker and I end I I had
him I had him stat it out really well
actually
I was um I was really proud of that
character and actually it was also I was
also really proud of the name of that
character so I played the droid I played
an astro joy which is the same kind of
general thing as r2 and he was our 3d0
also called redo because I had him stat
it as a joy that I got basically a
second shot at almost any hacking kind
of thing that I did uh I took a stupid
amount of pleasure in in that name your
way of drinking why is fancy I I'm not
sure it is
I drank straight from the bottle have
you watched Battlestar Galactica no I
haven't yet that is going to be remedied
in the near future because once I
finally finished doing Cowboy Bebop
yeah so by episode for the podcast feed
I'm gonna start watching Battlestar
Galactica for the first time so we'll
see have you ever listened to Eminem's
Big Finish
argh with five and I'm sorry what are
many mean I I don't know what that word
is um did you watch the original Star
Trek TV shows movies I never got into
the TV show because like my grandfather
would watch it sometimes but I I was in
my youth I had a really hard time
getting over how cheesy the effects for
I did watch the movies though I like I
watched voyage home especially a lot so
that like to me the I think original
Star Trek cast I tend to think of the
movies way
more than I do the TV show actually
you've got abscess
who's got absinthe I actually kind of
like absinthe it's got the kind of a
licorice thing going on which other oh
speaking of which okay
more people have sent me stuff and like
I don't know how long ago it was that I
said I hadn't had jelly babies before
but if you were here a couple of weeks
ago when I tried a whole bunch of stuff
that him excuse me that have been sent
to me including jelly babies which I've
now received more of which I ended up
not liking like very much at all but
here's the thing not only did I get
another bag of these I got these which
is a different brand so I guess
jelly babies are a bit like gummy bears
in the US where it's not like a specific
brand um but rather just like a general
shape and a thing that anybody can make
so I guess I will try now Sugarland
having tried previously
Maynard's Bassets which was not good do
can send the jelly babies to me which
plastic doctor would you want to face a
modern villain of your choice um oh jeez
um honestly I kind of like to see the
second doctor take on the silence I
don't blame you but jelly babies are
horrible okay
the sets are most well known well we'll
see how these are let's see do I have
any indication of flavors to go with
these no is that is that not a thing in
the UK is that just a u.s. thing because
like in the u.s. we can't we have a
tendency to put like a little a little a
little guide like what color is what
flavor
you folks don't seem to do that so much
okay well we'll try yellow
okay it's not great but better than
those other ones were okay that's that's
definitely better footing that we're on
and also like the faces on the other
ones were creepy like legitimately
creepy if you could collab with any who
tuber that you haven't collabed with
before who would you choose
well I'm trying and try to schedule with
wingy
like we've agreed on a topic and
everything is just trying to get
schedules lined up and it's it's always
made harder because of the because of
the time difference so I'm working on it
Purple's alright the yellow was better
purple is always the best way no
Purple's always the worst flavor cause
Purple's always grape that's the worst
that's always the worst rape is the
worst candy flavor except for a banana
like every now and then you get
something like laughs you Tavi does
banana why doesn't why why would you do
that oh and apparently that peak
chocolate bar thing from that couple
weeks ago that made me like um that that
was banana flavored which explains why I
had such a visceral reaction to it so
who had the idea of baby shaped candy I
don't know but they were disturbed is
there one thing you don't like about
each of the doctors probably but I'm not
sure I'm up for sorting that out right
now
purple is always blackcurrant why would
you make grape flavored splits uh okay
welcome to the u.s. Purple's always
grape and it's it's
I like bullet and banana Laffy Taffy
okay beach girl I'll send you mine
next time I end up with it what else
together here we go orange which
generally is orange grape is great hello
we started a sweet Wars in the chat love
it
have you ever seen quantum leap like
once like a random episode when I was
really young that I barely remember sex
ed ruined bananas no sex ed made bananas
sexy do you like how the doctor is a
coward most of the time yeah sure if you
could say the doctors coward most of the
time the doctor is a is frequently a
coward on first reaction his first
reaction is to okay let's run um he'll
go back and face it later bananas are
very good I like bananas bananas are
good all right green I know I don't know
what the green is yeah no that one's not
good oh I like Cola flavor must be the
only one yeah coke I like I don't I
don't drink soda anyway so like Cola
flavored candy is very weird for me like
as a thing I hate banette so the thing
that's weird about me and banana
flavored candy is I like actual bananas
but I hate banana flavored stuff I've
actually got the opposite thing going on
with watermelon I don't like watermelons
but I like watermelon flavored things
especially if they're alcoholic
can't stand fake banana flavor unless
it's a dirty banana what I think minute
lady got we're kind of on the same page
here in general
I hate paste see it's funny to me that
the doctor has the thing about pit I
love pears like under ripe pears is
probably my single favorite fruit needs
to be under ripe though I don't like
juice going down my chin green apple
flavored can't eat or soda isn't it
green apple is a good flavor here's my
here's my beef with the green apple oh
my beef with green apple at least here
in the US is for a while it's finally
like reversing after years but for like
a decade anything that was lime flavored
got swapped for green apple now I like
green apple but I also like lime
flavored like when's skittles did this
this ticked me off so much because and
cousin ruined the mix cuz I like to eat
skittles by taking a handful that is a
mix and eating that and the line there
was a it was a overall a citrusy thing
with with it kind of being softened by
the grape and the cherry a green apple
true that completely out of whack
so when season six finishes can you do
10 best and worst Brooklyn nine-nine
episodes
no because I am really far behind uh
Brooklyn nine-nine and I would have to
revisit a lot what's in the hip flask
not water
I don't even know what I grabbed there
thinking about the purple gun damn okay
so we've got a red and then then I'll
have tried all these I mean the yellow
was still the best out of this
I still don't love it but it's better
than the other ones um who has better
hair Paul McGann and the TV movie or
David Tennant oh boy I mean David
Tennant's style is more current than
McGann's yep oh is at this point in time
but sort of taking the that out of it I
think McGann had better hair
don't take the red one Daleks will have
none um that's okay I mean that's cherry
that's obviously cherry favorite
alcoholic drink depends on my mood as a
rule of thumb my go-to is is hard cider
other than that I tend to I tend to do
cocktails and battled and that'll just
be completely mood dependent it's
usually in case of seeing a cocktail
menu and going what is appealing to me
tonight
I don't drink straight alcohol very uh
like like hard alcohol very often I have
all on occasion but that's that's uh
that's an exception for me Oh actually
okay best thing ever there is a drink
that Liz came up with completely
accidentally by just throwing a bunch of
things together into a wine glass and it
is now like my favorite thing ever so
let me see if I can remember what's in
it its Moscato
ginger ale champagne
cranberry wine hard cider and there's
something else that I'm forgetting and
then there's like fresh berries like
raspberries or cut up strawberries or
blackberries and blueberries in it
and she called it very nonsense and it
is completely replaced mimosas as like
the best drink to have with brunch like
ever
oh it's amazing
compiled Dee's hair was its own
character I buy it by series ten I
really loved Capaldi's hair a lot like
yeah lion's mane it was incredible I
remember my ex used to love cafe patron
I now desperately want Pat I love
Moscato yeah no it's good it's good
stuff
do you do you think you will ever put a
short up on this channel again probably
not like I have no ideas for it like
it's it's possible that like I might
integrate some more scripted stuff into
the kinds of videos I already do like at
some point like I'm I kind of want to
try reworking the the format for 90s
comics free trial just experimentally so
you know maybe something like that but
like an actual scripted short like what
the channel used to be originally
originally now probably not I don't
really have a poll to go back and do
that kind of stuff and like I'm not sure
I'm not even sure I could write that
kind of thing now like I feel like my my
instincts as a writer I've moved on from
what I was doing back then I was at a
dance Saturday night and had a drink
called sex on the sex on the farm
I've heard of sex on the beach I've
heard of sex in the ocean sex on the
farm that's
new one I'm curious have you seen any
James Bond movies yes not all of them I
think you've probably seen about half
maybe a little more but I like Heidi I
don't like it enough to do laborious Lee
go through and see the ones that I
haven't seen yet cuz most one ones that
I haven't seen yet are not particularly
well regarded ones there's only a
handful of ones that I've missed that
are supposed to be any good so it's not
it's not high on my priority priority
list
I've got about got a bow out it's 2:30
a.m. here next week is yes so next week
will be 7 o'clock I I do the alternating
I know it's confusing that I don't keep
a regular schedule with this but it's
because it is because of the schedule
which I have my my daughter because her
mother and I switch off with her on
Wednesdays so that means every other
Tuesday I have her here and when she's
here I don't I like I can't start at
7:00 cuz I'm not gonna like you know
tell my kid to do her own bedtime so
that I can get on a livestream I I want
her to be in bed and then have enough of
a padding of time after that that I can
unwind a little before doing this
whereas next week she'll be with her
mother and I will just you know I'll get
home from work I have dinner and then
I'll talk with all you folks hey sorry
for the serious question but your grade
on LGBT issues any advice for a
non-binary person who's OCD who's OCD is
convincing them they're a turf okay um
I'm trying to parse all that so I I'm
slightly confused by the question I
guess in context I'm not entirely sure
I'm following what OCD means and
context maybe it's just the structure of
the of the question the way you ask that
I'm missing something but I'm I I want
to answer that I'm just not entirely
sure I understand the situation that
you're describing I mean I mean if you
want to if you want to take a crack at
clarifying it I'll do my best with it
sounds like a a bit of a rough situation
here my country there's a cocktail
called ass parody
I'm not gonna try a smurf sperm just
creamy and blue it's kérékou coconut
milk oh yeah I've had that bar I worked
at they just call this Smurfs Gia's so
you know say my same idea different we
went for the slang you went for the the
technical terminology I usually like
wine coolers in college but now I like
me the rum whiskey or Diet Coke
curious dude for the folks who are a old
enough to drink and B have been out of
college for a little while do you find
that like you come you almost completely
move away from the stuff that you drink
when you were in college cuz when I was
in college it was vodka and like Mike's
Hard Lemonade and I don't like either of
them now so Benjamin if if you're still
there you know you don't have to do
another donation to clarify the question
you can just ask and I'm keeping an eye
out for you to see if you do because
like I said I do want to I do want to
answer that and try and give some
perspective yeah if I can
feeling generous Thank You Tammy
I appreciate that quite a bit a favorite
Hori Hori my god take it on the drink
favorite horror movie creatures I mean
the the xenomorph is the single best
design monster in cinema
period end of story III don't even like
I don't know if anyone has an argument
against that if they do they're wrong it
doesn't mean the alien series is the
best thing on the planet it has two
great entries then a lot of weirdness
you look like my cousin Cindy into those
glasses she's cool and funny - oh good
I'm never really drank during my college
years I drink more after hitting my late
30s okay so you're making up for lost
time then I didn't drink in college I I
broke and studied all the time yeah
maybe if I drank less in college I would
have finished I'm bisexual I've been
struggling with the feeling that I'm
somehow not gay enough because I'm
inexperienced I know this is irrational
but I don't know what to do about it any
advice um Nathan that's that's a tough
thing and like
funnily enough I actually on reddit
today I ended up having a bat back and
forth with somebody who had a similar
thing but she was she was having trouble
with the label of gender-fluid because
the way she I'm I'm saying she because
she said that 95 percent of the time she
identified as female so that's kind of
why I'm going with that that description
she said that like it's a very narrow
margin of time that she feels anything
other than female so she felt worried
about using the term gender fluid and
you know I'll kind of say to you a bit
of what I said to her there isn't a
minimum quota you know if for her it
doesn't matter if 95% of the time she
feels like like a woman if at any point
her sense of gender wanders then she has
a fluid sense of gender and it's the
same with with bisexuality you could be
primarily attracted to only one gender
you can have only have relationships
with one gender but if you have
attractions genuine attractions whether
you have actually acted on them with a
partner or not for something other than
just one gender then
you have every right to the term
bisexuality there is anyone who says
that you're not by enough or you're not
gay enough or whatever that's
gatekeeping that is stupid and
destructive and and oftentimes weirdly
hateful so I always take a lot of issue
with that with that entire idea and that
and that whole concept that you you have
to be some certain percentage or balance
of these things in order to claim the
label and no it's that's not true you
just don't I mean I saw that somebody
like dropped the term heteroflexible
I've seen those like heteroflexible homo
flexible and they're not unuseful terms
I for my part I find those sort of
excessively specific terms to like start
to just clutter up the language a little
bit but they if that feels like a better
fit than bisexual try it on for size see
see if that feels better for you because
that that's the other thing you don't
have to change who you are to fit a
label better like my own philosophy is
to heck with the label so that other
people figure out what to call you but I
mean if labels for you comfort because I
knew they I know they do for some people
by all means
look around see if there's a label that
works better see answer helped me a lot
to help me as well thanks a lot oh thank
you everyone is preferences and there's
absolutely nothing wrong with that I'm
bisexual with a stronger preference for
males but I'm still bisexual I mean yeah
look I don't I don't really talk about
this but like I put a lot of emphasis on
the fact that my attractions strongly
lead towards women cuz they do and every
romantic relationship I've ever had has
been with a woman but like I am bisexual
I don't identify that like vocally very
often just because I end up getting a
flood of guys hitting on me and I'm
really not interested but like
technically speaking I am so you know
okay Benjamin here we go
uh sorry context alright sorry hang on a
second guys let me get this
OCD gives extremely intense intrusive
thoughts that make you cycle and believe
false things about yourself and tell you
and that's what you think
ie I get locked into gender essentialism
oh oh okay
I get what you're think I think I get
what you're saying now so what it sounds
like you're saying is the nature of your
OCD sort of needing to you know parse
things out and and have everything in
its proper place is clashing with your
own non traditional gender identity wow
man that if I am understanding this
correctly that is that is no easy thing
and like it I if you're saying you have
OCD I must I'm gonna assume that that's
diagnosed and I would hope that you
would have somebody that you can talk to
a therapist or or something of that
nature because I I feel like like that
kind of clash that kind of internal
clash going on in your in your head sort
of between your brain and your identity
that's that's something that somebody
who understands the ins and outs of your
condition is going to be in the best
position to give you the tools to combat
that
I mean dysphoria is
is one of those things that is I I feel
really bad not being able to offer more
advice on because I'm insanely lucky in
that I I've never really had body
dysphoria you know my internal sense of
gender shifting does not involve a
rejection of my own body it's not
because I because I mean I I know gender
flu people who have that who you know
what they'll have their sense of gender
shift and then you know when that
happens they'll have a sudden hatred of
whatever secondary or primary sex
characteristics they have that now
suddenly don't fit their gender identity
and they feel so wrong to them so I
don't have that and I'm ridiculously
lucky but it does unfortunately also
make me a little bit ill-equipped to be
able to advise on ways to cope with just
with dysphoria especially just severe
dysphoria because it's it hasn't been
part of my own experience so while I
like to think I kind of understand it
it's only through secondhand knowledge
so I mean yeah like I said Benjamin I I
really do think your best bet is going
to be to try and work with with a
professional in some capacity because
obviously when you're both of these
things that are clashing your identity
and your OCD are things that you can't
just decide to change about yourself you
can't just well you're just got a
knuckle downing get on top that well no
he's a fundamental truth of who you are
and they're at war with each other
and I yeah that's what you're dealing
here's what I will say your identity is
valid your struggle is super valid
and whatever assistance you can find
whether that whatever help might be in
the area that is as experienced and
knowledgeable and professional as you
can get I mean that's kind of what I'd
recommend just because what you're what
you're dealing with is is heavy so I
don't know if that helps since I
basically kind of punted the issue to a
theoretical other person for you to talk
to but that's I think that's kind of the
best I can do is the most helpful
livestream ever oh geez
thank you re um do you think James Bond
is an antihero I think he is now
he wasn't originally he was a very you
know just British imperialist kind of
hero but as that mold became less
acceptable and less PC they kind of
rather than completely retooled the
character into something that he wasn't
they were like okay well we'll just make
him rough around the edges more of a
babbling more of an antihero so that we
just sort of changed the perspective on
him without changing him completely um
thank you so much okay all right I'm I'm
glad to hear that Benjamin and and look
I'm I'm not always equipped to answer
every question but I will always try
will and
wellthen Graham the ultimate granddad's
I like Graham but nobody comes close to
wealth like they don't nobody even hold
a candle to will if you're talking you
know that granddad vibe have you ever
seen the show awake that was cancelled
after one season season nope not sure I
ever even heard of it I wanted to ask
you something because I'm on a club that
may come across it what is the
difference between sex and gender also
I'm trying to explain gender fluid and
other things to my friends okay super
basic and there are more learning people
who can give you
answer than I can sex your sex is your
physical gender is your physical state
your gender is your sense of self so the
classic like at this point most people
get the idea of transgender and
transgender is when your physical body
your your biological sex assigned sex
does not match the gender that you are
your sense of self is in conflict with
your body and so transgender people you
know trans men assigned female at birth
transition to men trans women assigned
male at birth transition to two women so
that's that's the basic bullet points
now gender fluid here's here's the best
metaphor that I have found that actually
works for both gender fluid and
non-binary and non-standard gender
identities which is that most people
tend to think of gender as a light
switch you know two positions on-off
it's either male or female that's it two
options pick one you just flip the
switch in one direction or the other and
even understanding transgender that
still kind of fits the binary that
there's two options Oh what transgender
people went for one and now they're the
the other what I find much more helpful
is to think of gender as a dimmer switch
you know the round ones that you can set
to all these little settings and it's
not just lights all the way on or
completely dark there's all these
settings in between and gender-fluid
people just kind of won't be the knob
won't stay put so that's that's sort of
the metaphor that that I've gone with I
like that a dimmer dial yeah I find I
find that that metaphor to be helpful I
really like Mickey's arc yeah Mickey's a
good stuff oh thank you
badger I appreciate that thanks for
answering my questions should help cool
hey I'm dropping out have a nice night
oh you too Emily
have you seen anything of the new addams
family animation will you be discussing
it on animation junkie um I've seen the
trailer I'm not gonna do a video on the
trailer because I don't have enough
thoughts about it like I'm it's gonna
take me a little while to get used to
that visual style like I get why they're
doing it it's much more the the original
newspaper cartoons that that it was but
like I'm getting used to that character
design I'll probably give it a look
because it's the kind of thing I think
my daughter will probably enjoy cuz she
I mean she likes that slightly dark
stuff she likes
Hotel Transylvania she likes Coraline
she likes ParaNorman so you know I
figured that that that's a good thing
for her did the long strange of things
hey it is kill your excitement somewhat
know season two killed my excitement all
on its own no hate is necessary
we should have it all versions when
watching things in different languages
like spirited away do you prefer subs or
dubbed I did a video on this I'll do it
super simplified more often than not I
will go with a dub because I it allows
me to first of all dubs are good now
like in the late nineties early 2000s it
was a crapshoot a lot of dubs were
terrible like one of my favorite anime
films is ghost in the shell' and I will
not watch it with a dub cuz the dub is
awful I almost swore it's really bad so
that one I'll watch the subtitles but if
the dub is good I'll watch it with the
dub because it's it's always weird to me
when people are like oh but and like I
understand the translation is often
slightly different they'll reward it's
likely to fit the mouth movements better
but like it's always struck me weird the
argument that oh you have to watch the
subtitle because the original language
is the intended experience I'm like I'm
pretty sure the intended experience was
not watching the bottom two inches of
the screen and reading like in my mind
that's way more disruptive to the
intended viewing experience then hearing
a different language is re has different
feelings because re is sub all the way
and I will not comment on that Miyazaki
is great to them I didn't think that
most things have really good dubs now
it's actually I cannot remember the last
time I heard a genuinely bad dub it's
been a long time do you hate it when
trans youtubers say gender fluid is fake
um I didn't realize that was a thing see
this is the thing I'm I'm super
selective about what corners of YouTube
I wander into so you know if if that is
let's go with not uncommon event for
transgender youtubers to denigrate or
invalidate gender fluidity which I mean
that doesn't super shock me cuz and
they're like I let me be clear I'm not
like saying transgender people reject
gender-fluid people my experience has
not been that but there are elements
within the trans community that are very
exclusionary and I have encountered that
before so I'm not shocked to hear that
it exists in some of the YouTube spaces
as well it's it's disappointing but is
what it is most underrated animated
series um I don't know my favorite anime
series us is escaflowne anime I feel
like that's on nobody's top 10 so there
you go and you watch critical role I
have not I know what it is I've heard of
it but no I haven't seen that one plenty
of sub in these parts hmm yes I I
noticed have you ever watched Voltron
legendary defender I have not uh-huh
thank you be good for a laugh when you
have an adult dub for a kid I mean like
if you if you get camp value out of it
sometimes a bad dub can be funny but
like as someone who doesn't particularly
enjoy cringe humor it doesn't really do
the so bad it's funny thing like I don't
get that entertainment out of it but I
know some people do have you seen Doom
Patrol yet I have not I don't know when
I'm gonna get to that I've heard very
good things about it I don't know when
that's gonna happen
I just remembered about your old green
screen
what the heck set that memory off
like what what on earth reminded you of
the green screen wow that's going back a
ways I have to head out have a girl have
a it's been grand good night and a good
night to you as well i watch everything
even in English with subtitles ideally i
watch with both but they rarely match up
yeah
would your go-to karaoke song I do not
sing karaoke as a rule of thumb I have
to be very tipsy to do karaoke because
the thing is most things I would be
confident in singing are things that I I
tend to gravitate to towards a small
selection of show tunes because that's
like I'm not I don't have a pop singer
voice and I know that and it drives me
crazy so like but my willingness to belt
out a show tune I need to I need to know
I've got a receptive audience to do that
so you don't like so bad it's good so
you don't like the Roma I've actually
never seen the room but that part of the
reason that I haven't is that's not that
old area of entertainment is not really
my bag why did you stop using the green
screen well three reasons one it adds to
the to the editing time to at least at
the time the editing software I had the
effect was not great um I got new
editing software maybe would be better I
haven't tested it because of number
three which is that I've only got one
room where I was willing to set it up as
a permanent fixture because it is a huge
pain in the ass to set up and take down
every time I want to use it but the room
that I was like oh I could set it up and
here has horrible acoustics plus it gets
cluster flies in the summer so like I
would try and shoot up there it's in the
attic actually I would try and shoot up
there and these freaking flies that are
like that big
are you can hear them on the audio and
they're buzzing they're flying in front
of my face I'm like no no I don't even
like the green screen that much not
worth it I prefer my my setup now quite
a bit I'm more Godspell than Jesus
Christ Superstar are you a good singer
uh once upon a time I was a good singer
I I was uh I made the Select chorus my
senior year of high school I'm like way
out of practice like I don't really
practice singing aside from like
occasionally in the car at this point
and part of the thing is I'm a baritone
which means I most most songs that are
like oh I love this song let's say that
they're not in my range like I say I
like to belt out the occasional show
show too but I have to be really
selective because most lead singing
parts in show tunes are either tenors or
they are in the upper register or
baritone and just out of my comfort area
that's true of a lot of even non show
tunes just songs and generally usually
slightly higher than I'm comfortable
hitting favorite or most bothersome
Harry Potter plot hole I mean it's the
first thing that leaps to my brain the
entire way that time-travel worked in
the curse child
ie not the way time travel worked the
last time they did it
are you gonna see Hellboy and have you
seen the ticket on Amazon I haven't seen
the tick Hellboy didn't show up anywhere
near me so I'll probably wait til
streaming that thing sounds like it was
I disaster I would love to be a soprano
spelled capitalised so I think your
meaning of the Tony variety
how how long do you have to be a $60
patient before you can Commission a
review every month that you do the $60
tier that's a review so that said I
don't always get to them within a month
of you having secured that I get to them
as quickly as I can but I actually guy I
went a while only having one a month
I've had a number of them kind of pile
up on me so I'm trying I'm playing
catch-up right now and like the the one
for monstrous regiment that was from
months ago but it was a 500 page book it
took me a while to get through it so but
but the way that tier works is once once
that comes through once that $60.00
comes through you have bought a
commissioned review with that so if you
stay at that level for more for another
month if you roll that over you just
bought another review so that's that's
how that works
oh I thought everyone just universally
agreed that cursed child wasn't canon
quite possibly but like that was the
first thing that came to my head
so having having to head now good night
okay good night there Knight Kayla have
you have you ever been swatted by the
FBI but I know of since you have said
that you are not out at work is there
anything you do to hide anything about
your body that might out you um well I
mean I I don't paint my nails I mean I
like this hand they're a little bit
grown out but like I get away with that
because like there's there's other
people with long that light including a
guy there's like a musician a couple of
cubicles down for me who has long nails
not that I claim to be a musician but I
mean guys with long nails
I get away with obviously I don't wear
you know frames like these and I have to
wear a sports bra at work these days
because yeah I've got curvature now so
that I have to strap down so that's a
thing
I've been wondering about to your
pricing too so thanks for the answer
yeah glad glad to help I feel like I
need to go back and look at how I have
that worded cuz I actually I've had that
question come up a few times recently so
I feel like I need to go back in and
take another look at that
Jodie's coat is allegedly changing for
series 12 what are you hoping for I
don't know I like that coat like I'm not
saying they can't change but like I feel
like the coat should be a constant like
I look at how much Capaldi changes the
coat stayed the same I don't know can
$60 patrons Commission book reviews yes
but if it's over 300 pages we might need
to negotiate up something higher than 60
because like I get I loved reading the
monstrous regimen but like I said 500
pages it threw off my schedule so yes
books are not excluded but depending on
how long it is we might need to talk um
I if you're the if you're the one who
emailed me the last week I actually
responded to that email earlier today so
if you want to hit me up back up on
email or DM on Twitter or whatever we
can figure it out do you think you'll
ever get to the point where you can be
out at work at the job I'm at now no no
I don't did you get your hairy code yet
nope this is what it's big so what it's
been for a while I mean you can tell be
it stops there when I get it diet I get
it died to the roots so I mean you can
see you can see how long it's been my
Buffy group is doing trivia next week
and i'm in charge of studying season six
I feel like curling into a
bawling-crying
oh yeah that one's gotta be rough but I
mean you you've got um once more with
feeling
at least that's something uh can I make
you watch anime if I become a $60 page
when it opens up so many possibilities
just kidding I'm broke like the $60 gets
you well for an hour-long show it'll get
you two episodes for something that's
like a half hour for um so like you at
the six-hour level you're not gonna be
able to Commission me to watch an entire
anime series but you could get me to
take on a few episodes but yes I I feel
you on the broke so yeah taxes Focus 288
pages that is viable then I would say
thoughts and Jodi
Whitakers and Jon Pertwee's title
sequence I'm not tightly sure why you
would compare the two and also would
depend on which Pertwee a title sequence
cuz I like the last his last season I
like that one best out of his I should
probably wrap it up soon I have gone
longer than they usually do actually I
III feel like I kind of gave up on
having structure for these I didn't mean
to I think I've just had a really
exhausting few weeks I didn't have it in
me to like come up with a plan for the
the stream but I think I'm gonna I'm
gonna wrap it up there
yeah structure of the Daleks lack of
structure is fine it can turn out
amazing
oh thank you like as long as you folks
don't feel like I'm wasting your time or
jerking around I'm you know I like doing
this this is still fun that's why I
still do it
um but yeah well wrap it up it's funny I
actually laid out the one thing I laid
out structure for was like drinking Iowa
I don't think any other questions that I
listed got asked that's okay I'm gonna
finish this off anyways um yeah who's
best eight from Hellboy a monster from
shape of water The Creature from the
Black Lagoon I mean uh like for who I'd
like to hang out with it's a but I mean
shaper waters the best movie oh my god I
love that movie
okay hope you all got 60 bucks that we
request a jello share live stream um the
last time I got really truly plastered
like to the point of like some of it
coming back up on me was on jello shots
I'm trying to be a little careful about
that
I'm not saying no I'm just saying I
might need somebody in the room to cut
me off but anyways I hope you all have a
good night good rest of your week oh
dang it there was one other thing okay
so I mentioned I've got it yeah
I've said good night now I'm adding
stuff I mentioned that I've got a show
this weekend so there will inevitably be
selfies going up for that but I'll
preview for you a part of the outfit
that that I'll be wearing for that I I'm
not doing a number I'm hosting so it's
gonna be fun so I hope everyone has a
good one and
Cheers